i'm joined today by dr. hugh Seeley who
is professor in the department of public
health and preventive medicine at st.
George's University it's so great to
speak to you know when we talk about
climate change and sea level rise it's
often sort of considered this problem
that somewhere out there in the future
and we still have plenty of time to make
sure there are no negative repercussions
from it but in Grenada this is already
an issue and it's not just grenade I
mean there are a number of island
nations around the world that are really
experiencing the negative effects of
climate change talk to us first
generally about that ah well thank you
very much for having me on the show
David yes i'ma leave me yoshi ater the
Alliance of small island states so on on
climate change issues and that this is
an alliance of all the islands in the
Caribbean in the Pacific Ocean in the
Indian Ocean and in the Mediterranean we
total 39 member countries in all about
father 195 of us or so that that
negotiate under the united nations
framework convention on climate change
so i represent a fairly large block of
countries that are particularly
vulnerable to climate change matter of
fact we argue that for majority of our
membership climate change is not an
economic issue it actually threatens or
actual existence and you mentioned sea
level rise of course that is that is a
particularly insidious threat in our
region of the world the sea levels are
rising at around three millimeters per
year that may not sound like much but
when you have done over over decades it
will just consume all of our reliance
infrastructure now to play devil's
advocate on that piece for a second you
will have what should I call climate
science deniers who say you know the
thing is David when you're talking about
three millimeters this could be cyclical
right we could see 30 40 years of a
three millimeter rise per year and then
just by the natural cycles of our planet
you will see a drop in the sea
what science do we have if any that
might do away with that talking point
well the latest report of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the IPCC which is this this group
of hundreds of scientists that do have
to represent doesn't so yes there is
some politics in there but they don't
generate the science themselves they
screen all of the scientific
publications and they come up with a
report once every five to seven years on
the latest report from them to fifth
assessment report out that we have that
came out Oh about two years ago zout was
unequivocal and in scientific terms
meant when someone tells you the other
ninety five percent certain in science I
mean we can't have any more certainty
that one kind of changes the current
unto that man kind has caused climate
change across three let me run out of
time but the kind of change is already
occurring and is a runaway train that
they were faced and now and we have very
very few years to to drastically change
or omission trajectory if we hope to
remain below 2 degrees Celsius of
warming another small island we said
that even two degrees was too much we've
asked for a long point to limit warming
to 1.5 degrees about pre-industrial
times and I was a success w one time in
2015 yes so as far as that goes i mean
when my audience hears you say well you
know 22 degrees celsius was too much so
we insisted on 1.5 and we got it
whatever sort of target point is put out
there what really matters is what the
policy is that will help us to achieve
that right and there's this idea that it
may already be too late i mean what's
what's the degree to which activities on
our planet would need to change in order
to achieve that we're running out of
time the the latest science that we have
says that we have a very very limited
carbon budget if any carbon budget left
at all to remain below 1.5 gb so so I'm
being realistic and recognize
and that to achieve this 1.5 people will
require a Herculean effort on the part
all nation this is like a global
Marshall time that we're asking for as
line and we recognize that and it was
very very hard to turn around a fossil
fuel world and I make that transition
you know in our energy sector but we
have to do it in the Solomon Islands
there are already five islands that
since 1947 have gone completely
underwater there are a number of
tourists islands off the coast of
Thailand that have had to suspend
tourist activity because of sea level
rise and the impact that it's had on
coral reefs is your sense that in the
next 50 years it's just inevitable that
there are going to be some parts of the
world that used to be places of business
places of tourism that will have to be
abandoned by the human race yes I think
that's not inevitable I think that we
have we have locked ourselves into at
least one metre of sea level rise in
u.s. terms of a little bit over three
feet but nothing I was that will occur
no matter what we do from here on the
end so I when I when I speak to two or
ministers of finance and planners in our
small island outside I tell them we have
to recognize that and we're going to
have to remove vulnerable infrastructure
and people away from or cosine and I'm
some years will no longer be viable
settlements what I'm trying to do is
save or is safe to save the islands that
themselves recognize that we are already
going to lose part that's the
unfortunate thing and I am I dosa for
myself on the coastline here in England
Anna and I and I I wonder whether the
other pass it on to my children hmm when
we think about who might be the best
partners worldwide in terms of fighting
the effects of climate change
particularly watching incoming Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson confirmation
hearing yesterday and hearing
say that you know the it's sort of in
doubt the impact that that humans are
having on the climate my sense is that
the Trump administration in the u.s. is
not going to be one of the key players
and curbing climate change in emissions
who are the key players in your mind
that are better the real strategic
partners over the next ten years it's
China one of them is India another well
i think that the US and China are the
two elephants in the room I think that
without the us-china agreement pre to
time we would not have gotten the power
to people that was the bowels of
fundamental that the US and China had
agreed to themselves on ignition
trajectories that they were going to
follow and that made the pirate
agreement terrible what will happen in
the future yes the u.s. pulls out of the
power experiment is is one of conjecture
and I'm not prepared to go there yet
David I'm going to remain an optimist
and on the whole mr. Tillerson if he is
confirmed as the secretary state is
probably one of the most informed
secretary states about climate change as
it as the former head of ExxonMobil he
had access to the data that I she most
of us build ha right I waited at exile
oval we now know covered up for 40 years
about the impact on Long flame there i'm
just saying that he has access to the
data yellow lee not be but but but he
knows the economic impacts of climate
change the only what it will cost to to
avert and the kind of change in between
and at that to kind of change but also
the impacts will have on existing
industries that rely on fossil fuels so
he's actually perfectly placed to help
us make that transition so i'm gonna
wait and see mode i can i can say he was
with with again optimism by the power to
give me cannot be stopped all the world
has signed on to the piracy name
including the United States in the
United States wishes to withdraw and
that would be extremely unfortunate then
what that would mean was of the United
States the bulk of the sidelines again
because it was on the sidelines of the
Kyoto Protocol
if it personalizes go to the side bangs
again the game or push will continue
last thing i want to touch on any time
we talk about curbing emission limiting
energy use etc it's much easier to get
agreement from people sort of in the
abstract that other than the climate
science deniers that this is something
we need to address but when the rubber
meets the road and you say here is how
everybody's day to day energy
consumption would have to change for us
to achieve what we need to achieve or
what we're looking to achieve it's much
harder to get buy-in from people who are
very comfortable based on the the
benefits and luxuries that fossil fuels
bring to us what's the best way to have
that conversation with people to explain
the urgency of this pack that's an
excellent question and it's what I've
struggled with here at ten George's
University we are an American University
here in Grenada I teach American
students public health and one of the
things I say to them and I try to
personalize this is I say all of us how
to reduce our carbon footprint as a
typical American repro get around 20
tons of co2 beer we're going to have to
drop that to less than say six but does
that mean that you're going to lose your
SUV does that mean that you're going to
eat your plasma TV not necessary the
technology that we have in the world
today with renewable energy with
increased energy efficiency I do not
think that combating climate change
means that we're going to lose our way
of life did the typical American Way of
life that's a myth that that's that's
being perpetuated we're going to have to
do some paradigm shifts in the X in the
way that we put usage but we've already
learned that we can be coupled economic
growth from increased energy emissions
the United States is actually proven
that in the end it in the last year
again I remain optimistic at your feet
bring technology to beer if we have the
political will to transform our energy
industries and there will be some that
lose the coal industry will lose the oil
industry will lose but they will be
replaced and we will have all of the
energy that we require
I will have the quality of life that we
all desire well I don't share your
optimism but I like that you're
optimistic because I hope that you're
right in that optimism we've been
speaking with dr. Hugh Sealy professor
at st. George's University really
appreciate you talking to me about this
thank you for having me on the show